you talked about me too you said
something very interesting that me too
was kind of gonna be used
as the precursor for a lot of social
control
you know a lot of compliance you know
this idea that
uh we want you know people that are not
asking too many questions
or complying um and i'm sure people
don't
get a little angry with you for that
stuff on twitter people get a little
angry for you
paglie always brings up the great point
that men and women have worked
separately
uh for hundreds of years you know for
all of history and like
men and women working together all the
time in the proximity they are is a
relatively new phenomenon
and some of the things that come up or
you know somewhat understandable
go into the me too as a precursor for
compliance i think that's a very
interesting concept
yeah i mean yeah i mean i guess the
trick
is that again like all of these things
are were already made kind of
economically and viable i think like my
gloss on on me too
is fairly kind of like a cynical and
unforgiving
i think like the kind of tiny brain read
was that it was a justice movement
the mid brain read was that it was a
revenge movement which by the way the
most
kind of intelligent sophisticated
advocates of me too acknowledged were
just getting
revenge on men and they were playing by
their rules
um the the third tier kind of large
brain take was that
this was a labor movement that it was a
changing of the art of the
guard they were sweeping out the old
guard and replacing it with new blood
i.e women and minorities and then i you
know for me there's like this fourth
tier
um that's like pat the galaxy brain take
that this is kind of a psychologically
motivated it's a psychosexual movement
which i again i'm like doing my greatest
hits i've said this like a million times
but i
women think they're mad at men because
they're hostile and aggressive and
they're really mad at men because
they're
uh ineffectual and
indifferent right because men and women
you know for the same spots in the
workplace men now
view women as economic and professional
rivals
so there's this like weird kind of
psychosexual pulsion
there there is like me too does feel
very often like a provocation to men
right to take the baby which they won't
because you know
for for various reasons
demoralized and non-productive or
whatever um but i think
more than that my biggest fear with me
too had nothing to do with sex or gender
it had to do with the fact like right
away like you know
i i feel like i clocked it had to do
with the fact that it was
a kind of dry run address rehearsal for
the broader
erosion of due process that we're seeing
um right now across professional spheres
especially like
in tech and in media so you know people
getting fired
dismissed like canceled whatever that's
this sort of thing
and i think like it was very again i
don't know if it was like
conscious but it was very tactical
because um
me too is appealing for a host of
reasons mainly
because you cannot argue with a victim
or else you're an unreasonable monster
right right
you can't argue with like that it's
general slogan of believe women because
if you
problematize if you call into question
that slogan it must mean that you don't
believe women and then what kind of a
person are you
i just i also have a problem with who
society claims are victims
you know i quote tweeted david hogg
today because he's now coming up with a
new pillow
because the my pillow guy is you know i
don't know alt-right he's making an
alt-right pillow so david hogg's not
trying to make a progressive pillow
and i just don't yeah have you heard
about the
david hogg the parkland kid david hogg
is one of those crisis actors okay yeah
yeah no
he is he's he's he's a mealy mouth
he um is making a progressive pillow but
here's the thing
i don't think any of these kids are
victims i would have loved
to be in a school shooting and survived
i don't know that that's insane i mean
think about that
to be in a school shooting and to have
survived
are you a victim after you're a victim
during it but when you come out the
other side are you still a victim
this is the last week of our youtube
channel man thank god we are in texas
because we
this will be the last week of our
youtube channel
um but that's a great point you can't
argue with certain people